comment t'appelles-tu
you 7
millions comment aimer
des chinois
hobbit youssef dix mois
d'où
des vietnamiens
depuis le 1er juillet 74 la france à
limiter l'immigration les entrées de
travailleurs permanents dans notre pays
sont passés de 130 mille ans 74 à 67
milan 75 ne reste pas moins que plus de
quatre millions d'étrangers vivent
actuellement en france 220 milles en
lorraine la moitié d'entre eux exercent
une activité professionnelle
les permis d'évaluer à 500 mille le
nombre de travailleurs immigrés ne
parlant pas ou très peu le français le
phénomène prend une nouvelle dimension
lorsque ces travailleurs étrangers font
venir leurs familles il faut alors
intégrer les enfants à l'heure actuelle
dans l'académie de nancy metz quarante
mille immigrés vont à l'école onze mille
d'entre seulement fréquentent le
secondaire c'est peu par rapport aux
quelque 600000 scolarisés intégrer les
immigrés c'est l'un des voeux les plus
chers du secrétaire d'état poehl dijoux
et bien cette intégration passe par
l'école depuis plusieurs années
fonctionne des classes d'initiation une
trentaine actuellement lorraine et puis
depuis quatre ans nancy l'école
d'adaptation des grands moulins le but
de la classe et donc de leur apprendre à
parler français
également de leur apprendre à écrire et
à lire donc ça fait beaucoup de choses à
la fois puisque les remettre à niveau
pour les intégrer dans des classes
française puisqu'ils sont amenés enfin
sentiment
véritable mosaïque que cette école où le
faut retrouver sur le visage des 175
enfants les ex colonies françaises
portugaises ou espagnoles
175 enfants âgés de 6 à 17 ans répartis
en huit classes est représentatif de 17
nationalités
maghrébins surtout mais également
asiatiques sud américains ou européens
un dénominateur commun ses enfants dans
leur grande majorité sont arrivés en
france analphabètes ou non scolarisés
parachute et parfois même c'est le cas
des réfugiés politiques
c'est le cas d'ivan nova un chilien de
13 ans qui a quitté son pays il ya
quelques mois
c'est le cas encore de pannes thi kim
l'âme une jeune vietnamienne
le premier trimestre on leur apprend le
français la langue française est
rangèrent va devenir langue véhiculaire
au cours du deuxième trimestre outre est
plus sérieusement le problème de l'écrit
point grammatico et c est au cours du
troisième trimestre
on fait des choses beaucoup plus
intéressantes
et plus du tout question de programmes
scolaires on s'occupe beaucoup plus de
leur pays la géographie l'histoire et en
même temps fait du français attend la
france et la langue française constitue
le trait d'union entre ces enfants venus
des cinq continents ne reste pas moins
que cette expérience unique en france
pose de multiples problèmes
le gros problème c'est
qu'ils apprennent à parler
tout cela on a donc des méthodes
audiovisuel mais qui ne peuvent être
effective que lorsque les enfants sont
assez peu nombreux c'est à dire 15
maximum or nous en avons toujours
beaucoup plus que 15
souvent il arrive que deux grands
enfants de kizomba de même nationalité
se bat mais insensiblement et avec notre
aide
les enfants arrivent comprendre qu'ils
ont les mêmes problèmes dans cette école
on veut que les enfants continuent à
apprendre leur langue apprendre à la
parler à l'écrire
ça nous permet
de pouvoir faire des comparaisons entre
leurs systèmes cris est le nôtre autre
problème par exemple celui de
l'alimentation différentes selon les
races de la façon de manger les petits
asiatiques se sont vus dans l'obligation
d'abandonner la baguette pour la
fourchette problèmes d'ordre
psychologique et familiale obligeant
l'instituteur à se transformer en
assistant social
pensez vous franchement que ses enfants
pourront reprendre le cycle normal des
français
question difficile
pour handicapés certains indéniable ah
oui ça vous départ c'est sûr nous allons
vous lorsqu'ils sortiront chez voulons
qu'ils combler pour la plupart oui les
plus jeunes il n'y a pas de problème on
les garde un an les plus grands on est
obligé de garder quelques fois deux ans
cette expérience n'est pas parfaite loin
s'en faut laisser la plus satisfaisante
pour ces enfants qui auraient peut-être
même certainement préféré demeurer dans
leur pays